hey this is presh talwalkar
i have found three consecutive integers
such that their product is equal to
their sum
what could my numbers be
solve for all possibilities
i received this problem by email and i
give credit to ken edwards for creating
this puzzle
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
let's suppose the middle number is x
then the three consecutive numbers would
be x minus one
x and x plus one
we need the product of these three
numbers to be equal to their sum
this means x minus one times x times the
quantity x plus one
needs to be equal to x minus one plus x
plus x plus one
we can simplify the sum
to be exactly three x
we can find the product slightly easier
if we multiply x minus one times x plus
one because this will lead to a
difference of squares
x squared minus one squared which is one
we then distribute the x and we get x
cubed minus x is equal to 3x
we now group the x terms on the left
hand side and we have the cubic equation
x cubed minus 4x is equal to 0.
we can then factor out the x
and then we have x times the quantity x
squared minus four
this is a difference of squares which we
can factor
as the quantities x plus two and x minus
two
we can now see there are three solutions
to this equation
x equals zero x equals negative two and
x equals two
each of these solutions will lead to a
triplet of numbers
we have
one case of minus one zero and one
we have another case of negative three
negative two negative one and we have a
final case of one two and three and
these are the only triplets of
consecutive integers in which their sum
is equal to the product
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions which you can follow on
facebook google plus and patreon you can
catch me on social media at
preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description